the DeSantis anti-woke obsession
is not only fascistic in its Origins I
believe it's also bad strategy because
it doesn't reflect the views or or
interests of even if you don't want to
say of most Americans of roughly half of
Americans according to recent polls a
majority of Americans support teaching
about racism support teaching slavery in
schools oppose Banning books that deal
with those issues a majority of
Americans more than ever before support
LGBT rights and immigration reform and
voting rights all of that stuff is
actually as popular or more popular than
any other positions on those issues and
so DeSantis ends up alienating himself
from mainstream public opinion and
Catering to a fringe base that's driven
by fear and resentment and scapegoating
and bigotry